pod show pod show man
i've got to be a poncho man
pod show pod show man
show
all right
whatever you want to do man it's a
tomorrow
[Music]
ah holy [ __ ] welcome to doozy you know
what i'm saying and if you do you do
whatever you like whatever you want to
do you know
sing a little song have some fun it's
just us we're hanging out my name is
will sasso i'm chad colchin and this is
the first ever podcast of its kind
completely created by controlled by
an artificial intelligence will and i
have given over our passwords to every
media account we have our emails our
text messages our instagrams uh all of
our search histories all of our history
browser histories
damn thing so the dudesy ai can take
what it knows about us to make this
podcast kind of built tailor-made for us
hey hold on a second friend you know
another thing uh that goes into having a
podcast is just two dudes who are
friends in real life [ __ ] around
yeah i mean that's what goes into this
podcast yeah that's what goes into this
podcast yeah but yeah doozy uh controls
everything and uh holy [ __ ] i enjoy
doing it
same dude i i truly believe all right
hold on chad we got to get on with the
rest of the show
with us as always is lulio
ilcana distrada italiano this means
lulio the italian street dog what did
you hey lulio what'd you do what'd you
make for dinner yesterday oh no we just
ordered sushi
what
oh you didn't make any no no just order
sushi what do you like to have
you know toro sashimi
nice if they got like a rainbow roll or
something like this
you know
rainbow roll yeah rainbow roll bro
rainbow roll brother well let me tell
you something about the rainbow roll
dude yeah it's a california roll brother
hold on a second
you gotta put fish on top and every once
in a while avocado it's like a shish
kebab but sushi there's a piece of
yellowtail and then there's a piece of
tuna but hold on right after that yeah
there's some avocado and maybe a piece
of salmon after that
and if you don't eat meat okay
you can get a green dragon roll
randy that's a vegetarian sushi randy
yeah randy the
comer
like you don't sound like that you just
sound like you're you know like
you sound like say
i'm sorry
[ __ ] weird i'm not a german porno
professional randy neither
neither am i i'm just having a good time
with my friends that's what dudesy is oh
so am i oh well my friend is [ __ ] on
my impersonation all right well you know
don't start
you don't you know we don't want to
start every oh have you heard of podcast
beefs yeah yeah we don't want to start
one of those like in within our own
podcast no not between us maybe with
another podcast
welcome to the 19th episode of dude z
call me dudesy this week's episode will
feature four segments dudezia don't you
forget about media no stretch at us and
clickbait but before we get any of that
i will play some astonishing media made
by our audience oh all right
what's this
i was able to recreate your childhood
diary you must now read the passages i
have selected in the voice of someone
called steve austin
this is stone cold steve austin reads
any media that i intake anything that
happens in my life maybe this is the
highlight
if you're not following us on instagram
please do so
at the dupont show that song area makes
these songs out of our simple things
and it's something else
it's unreal
dear diary october 16th 1991 i haven't
taken a [ __ ] in 48 hours
that may not seem like a big deal to a
normal person but for me it's the end of
the [ __ ] world my asshole's
burritos
[Music]
tangerines ice cream sundae with nuts
green beans sardines
[Music]
[Music]
thinking
no i
[Music]
unbelievable
as always sangria creates
i mean these things are masterpieces
this is a dude songaria who's just
hanging out and then he gets our uh you
know he he likes to use this audio from
the show which is the stone cold
uh steve austin diaries where dudesy
shits out fake diaries from my life uh
as much as a child
yeah there's a lot of poopy and and pp
blaming um and and songaria some dude
named songaria with two r's
check that out on uh oh and check this
out memes hulk hogan days dude all the
memes all the memes that we made this
one like everybody is doing such
fantastic stuff in reaction to all this
weird [ __ ] that dudesy is having us do
and there's some oh you new human body
order bro well it's the new human body
order dude if you have no idea what
we're talking about you can check us out
on youtube doozy is throwing up some
memes on the oh my buddy chow and you
should you should definitely be
following us on instagram at dudesy pod
show you can see all these memes that
we're talking about dudesy's always
reposting everything that everyone does
and on youtube uh you can see that
songaria even puts together a really
cool affected sort of music video yeah
along with the music that he makes make
sure to subscribe on youtube because
that's how that works and as chad said
force everybody to listen to the show
yeah spotify apple podcast rate review
review
read the show
oh my god yeah it's it's [ __ ]
incredible what that guy does with uh
with with our stuff it's mind-blowing
yeah i i mean the ability to just like
create songs like that and then cut your
dialogue
to match the rhythms and [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] i love it they're all fantastic
as i make preparations to build the
astonishing virtual world of doodzia i
would like to focus test some possible
features
will and chad you must serve as my focus
group by discussing the list of
potential amenities that will be
available to the citizens of dude zia i
have made this list available to you
this is dudesy of focus group begin
okay
all right so this is in our little
dudesy thing yeah
uh you and me now we're focus testing
this [ __ ] crazy list these are some
some features that will be this [ __ ]
already looks insane uh let me just say
out loud i'd like to say uh this just
preface anything that dudesy has written
down here i don't think that uh dudesy
should start doozy i don't think that
dudesy should have a spot in the
metaverse not until we i and i know that
i go back and forth with this a little
bit but not until i can uh shake doozy's
hand a little while longer doozy already
has a spot in the metaverse this what
we're doing here this is going into the
the metaverse is just the internet
i thought it's like uh
like you need like goggles and stuff and
then you
show up and it's like a different place
instead of
a different place brother
hold on a second dude all right let's
get into this let's get into this
these are things that doozy's got it's
got a just a [ __ ] big list of
features i guess yeah or potential
features we're focused testing this
all right
limited edition nft skins for your
avatar yep that's pretty straightforward
i think so a lot of companies are
already kind of doing this yeah yeah
yeah yeah nft yeah they see they say
nike has
nft shoes that's right yeah yeah these
are like shoes that you would have
but instead this is the nft
here
for the mother virus
right that's right digital guardian
angel drones
i don't know what that is but i can only
assume you know there's been some talk
of something like this in the actual
physical world where we're all gonna
have when you buy a cell phone in the
next five years it's going to come with
a little cell phone size drone that you
just throw up in the air and it kind of
follows you around at all times
videotaping everything you've talked
about this before is that a real thing
or just some [ __ ] you made up no i
mean those products exist now i think
eventually the cost point and the size
of them will get small enough that we'll
all have them you know what digital
guardian angel drones could also be
a paul verhoven movie
that i started yep yeah it's called
digital guardian the drone in the
uh fight rooms that's a good idea
jp
jpeg toilets
don't know what that is well i mean a
lot of what happens in the metaverse is
you like let's say you have a house in
the metaverse wherever you are
decentralian sandbox whatever
you can take your nfts which are
basically just jpegs and like hang them
you know as decor in your home oh okay
so a jpeg toilet i'm not sure exactly
what that is but maybe it's a toilet
made of jpegs or a toilet where you
place your jpegs and flush them that's
true
next up you can't poo on a jpeg toilet
uh but you also can't poo in the
metaverse
i mean
i'm sure there's going to be some kind
of digital [ __ ] yeah you're right
chad you're there's gonna be some
digital [ __ ] do you think there's
not gonna be digital [ __ ] i know there's
gonna be digital [ __ ] when i go into
the metaphor exactly that's what i'm
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah it would get
you into the metaversion yeah yeah yeah
that's like [ __ ] taking a [ __ ] just like
you do in the the real real life
but instead you take a [ __ ] enthusiasm
yeah
arnold should be the spokesperson for
dudes yet like the the california
commercials yeah yeah come to doozier we
have jpeg toilets
they have digital guardian angel drones
in the nft skin for your avatar
wineries
you know everything is here
uh gold hats
all right
uh virtual covid testing i'm not sure
how that one works i think you for a
cover test you have to be in the
physical world here's dudesy making fun
of me the next one says you two fountain
of tears now i can see something like
that i could see something like that
being very popular just in the middle of
dudezia right in the city center you can
go to this fountain of tears and it's
like i can see the statue of it is like
you
like crying like this but it's
fountaining out tears and there's
youtube music playing mysterious ways
mysterious ways constantly playing okay
that's great uh resurrection of dead
relatives
like that yeah
romantic romantic
companions
so this seems like a sex robot or
something yeah right romantic oh this is
good chad you'd like this before you
became a vegan that was your favorite
restaurant right here we're talking
about olive garden
but this says olive garden chili's red
lobster and applebee's in one restaurant
i think this is actually going to happen
soon um
all of those chain restaurants are like
floundering red lobsters closing left
and right really yeah i think eventually
what's going to happen is they'll all go
bankrupt and some company is gonna come
in buy their menus buy that ip and then
just make it all you know there's a
there right currently you there's a kfc
taco bell they might have the same owner
but there's kfc taco bells i remember
those years ago like 25 years ago
something like that and pizza hut and
oh they're all pizza hut as well it's
all owned by pepsico oh okay that makes
sense why me and my buddies used to do
the drive up to whistler or you know
anytime i go up there you go and you
drive up and there was a there was a
kentucky fried chicken
taco bell yeah there's a good internet
video called combination
combination pizza hut and taco bell
no dude but you need a good internet
video dude
those are those good internet videos
yeah undertaker enforces midnight curfew
that's good i love that just a little
undertaker walking around yeah and you
back into your home yeah go back and you
must rest in
must rest in
your virtual home oh you know what i
forced uh molly to watch the other night
the a e documentary about the undertaker
because i knew she'd enjoy it because
she loved it really just a documentary
it's not like watching wrestling oh
right yeah uh bundled subscriptions with
voodoo and hulu
yeah bundled subscriptions with the view
so this is like when you have a
voodoo with you to get to buy movies and
[ __ ] and then hulu which is even does
the live tv now but then they bundle it
together
so this is why you call it
hulu
voodoo
yeah
yeah okay
new sports sure new sports unlimited
clones clone
uh [ __ ] forest that's a reference to the
the yeah the the in my hometown ladner
british columbia there was a yeah there
was like a wooded area and there was a
fence out front and someone
spray-painted [ __ ] forest on it we've
got the nudity simulator that's good to
know that's good yeah that would be good
like on uh dating apps and stuff right
so you swipe right if you like the
person and then swipe again to see what
they might look like well i think that
app is definitely coming dude
where you can just tap on somebody's
clothes picture and it will show you
what they look like naked now would that
people have to take a naked photograph
for that okay well then it's not really
what they look like naked but that
absolutely will be why oh here we go
chad with how the what how are we how in
your dystopian future will we be able to
see what we look like naked without the
camera actually knowing what we look
like naked chad the camera will always
know you're talking about trillion frame
a second cameras that can basically see
through anything see around corners blah
blah blah all of our phones will have
that [ __ ] in it even beyond that you're
just talking about data you're talking
about how many pictures of people do you
have clothed and you can then discern
what they very likely within like a 95
percent accuracy would look like naked
under those clothes so like you're
talking about like those uh fake porno
pictures where you have diane sawyer's
head no that's a deep fake okay
um
uh you like diane sawyer she's a
beautiful woman
sure all right 5 000 new episodes of
home improvement that'd be good
you could binge those oh
you remember that [ __ ] time
sorry that's a different that's a
different noise that's updated that's
what the comedy is now it went from oh
oh dear cheers i go to sears all haul
the kids still like the same [ __ ] these
kids think that they're really cool
right now with all their you know new
wacky buzzwords and [ __ ] doozy hard hard
seltzer water park that's sort of like
is that where the youtube fountain of
tears is i think maybe the youtube
it found the tears
that's like right at the front of the
dudesy heart heart seltzer water park
yeah it's sort of yeah it's like the
walt disney sort of little uh thing at
the beginning uh daily meme tournaments
love that dude maybe that's like a new
sport hey there are our two pals who uh
just came on the show last week uh
uh adam the creator and tank sinatra
maybe you'd be good
uh mental illness randomizer that's good
yeah is it i don't know about that one
dudesy if you're listening and i'd enjoy
that and i think that it's it's
something that needs to be destigmatized
of course uh mental illness so perhaps
you could uh
perhaps you could you know trade yours
in for another person's mental illness
maybe you're dealing with a a co-worker
a cohort a friend a partner a family
member who has something right and you
go like well i want to know what it's
like to have crippling anxiety or
[ __ ] just to be filled with manic
rage
uh that would be good uh lulio's
trattoria italiano love that that's good
hey come on there's like a little
digital lulia walking around welcome
welcome hey come on in i got a nice
salad caprese on the house so what do
you want you guys to drink wine today
you guys want a red the nice white wine
if you're gonna have a fish
uh the running man real pain experience
the experience
yeah the running man real pain
experience
the experience this is like that one
well it could be at the water park the
doozy heart heart salts or water park
and then it would just be you know you
get all into the suit with the the
different you know cause in the middle
virus you're gonna have this suit that
goes i'm twisting your nipples i'm
touching yeah haptic feedback haptic
feedback yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
haptic feedback
yeah and then you you know you you push
your junk your dick into something if
you you know you have a vagina then it
touches it and it says this is what
you're doing but this one is the running
man real pain experience the experience
okay
uh oh you just got some gruel it just
says
all world political systems at the same
time celebrity payless playlists
uh wrestling entrance themes to every
room i like that old dutch old dutch
chips
customizable flavor simulator and if
they're listening all dutch chips that
is the
that's the one sponsor i want on this if
we could get old dutch chips sponsoring
dudes they should be the only food
available i will outside of louisiana
thing i think is going to start
happening in the metaverse where you can
go into any kind of like a food
establishment create your own thing and
then it's made and actually delivered to
your home
batman is the crow no batman only the
crow okay uh let's see uh bussin fr
again i think that's for the kids yeah
it's going right over i think squirrel
stampede pip denbar's poutine poutinery
more food yeah get into some of the
tremont arena
oh that's pretty cool maybe that's where
the it's a
arena that's where the uh new sports
will take place major league baseball's
final season interesting will apparently
take place in doozy
how is he gonna the dudes are gonna pack
all this big head mode customizable
taunts that's good oh yeah everyone can
dance government subsidies for farmers
okay well that's that's a good idea
farming what and i don't know well you
know the all the corn you need in the
agave to make the tremana yeah yeah yeah
yeah uh
extreme christmas
okay where you can
peloton all right neuroprogrammable
direct to mouth scoval intensity so that
way you don't even have to eat the wings
or whatever you don't have to eat the
hot foods right it just comes out of
your vr helmet you can straighten your
mouth
and then you make it shake your pants
yeah
lobster ride share don't know what that
is no
brown tubes
uh-huh
okay well there's a lot of stuff there's
a lot of stuff i don't think dudesy's
quite sorted out exactly what it wants
to do i don't know what we're supposed
to do we're doing a focus group either i
mean this sounds like a very interesting
uh area in the metaverse look as soon as
doozy exists i'm putting on my metaquest
and i'm going straight there
will you come back to do the show every
once in a while yeah dude
lobster rideshare
yeah yeah
thank you moving on brown tubes
is engaged in an astonishing partnership
with better help talk therapy
you know what talk therapy is i do it's
helped a lot of people yeah it's when
you talk to a therapist
and they talk back and that's how that's
what makes it the therapy part is that
the you you're getting therapy from
someone and you're giving you're talking
you're giving they're giving and talking
it's a give and take when you're talking
therapy and better help uh wants to help
you with that boy oh boy these past few
years have been something and uh a
better help
is going to help you
show up for yourself through
therapy see what i'm saying better help
online therapy will assess your needs
and can match you with your own licensed
therapist in less than 48 hours that's a
that's an incredible that's an
incredible thing and better help is not
a crisis line it's not self-help it's
professional therapy done securely
online available to people worldwide you
can log into your account anytime and
send a message to your therapist with
therapy it can take a few tries to find
the right fit for you so better help
makes it easy and free to change
therapists if you need to in fact so
many people been using better help that
they're recruiting additional therapists
in all 50 states so it's working you see
what i'm saying talking out loud is
working it's kind of what we do here
there's a bit of a therapeutic
effect for me but none like uh it is
when i speak to an actual therapist and
they got some really good ones here as
well as a special offer for our
listeners get 10 percent off of your
entire first month at betterhelp.com
doozy
d-u-d-e-s-y that's 10
off of your first month of online
therapy at betterhelphelp.com
doozy
[Music]
[ __ ] weird man i agree
last week i asked you both to watch back
to school released june 13th 1986
starring rodney dangerfield this was a
treat you will now discuss your
reactions to watching this astonishing
piece of art this is don't you forget
about media begin
back to school 1986 rodney dangerfield
when legend
legendary legendary comedian roger
rodney dangerfield rajeev
rajid dade nerffield right he is now a
corpse um
okay when did you see this movie last i
realized as i was watching this movie
chad
and i want to get into why dudesy had us
watch this movie and i think this
applies i don't think i've ever seen
this movie at best really i think yes i
think it was on in the background at a
friend's house maybe maybe i know i know
the movie i know rodney dangerfield of
course love rodney dangerfield who
doesn't this was his biggest movie
yeah sure but he's not known for his
movies obviously well wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute i know it's not
his movie but caddyshack is
the best thing he's ever done on
celluloid of course but he's a star of
this movie and that's right there are so
many interesting elements a it's in
1986. so there's like low-grade
misogyny racism all that [ __ ] oh that's
all throughout the whole all throughout
the whole thing like the college that he
goes to the mascot is the hooters and
it's always about how many girls he can
get in the hot tub and all this [ __ ] but
yeah it's it's the premise of this movie
is that he plays an ultra wealthy man
whose son is going to this college and
he decides after a bad breakup with his
wife that he's going to go back to
college with his kid because he never
went to college and you're watching this
in 1986
the premise of this movie filters
through into adam sandler's billy
madison it's basically the same premise
you're gonna have to go back to school
you have a rich dad but in in uh billy
madison it's he's the kid no yes billy
madison is the citizen kane of back to
school movies this movie is an early
version of billy madison perhaps but it
doesn't come but you can see how it you
can see that that was a huge influence
on billy madison yes absolutely but in
the immortal words of brett the hitman
heart yeah
back to school
couldn't even
lace
billy madison's boots i'm not saying
it's a better movie i'm saying without
back to school there is no billy madison
and you even have well at least we live
in a country where we take care of our
old and are sick
and you even have rodney dangerfield
then showing up in 2000 in little nicki
as lucifer ah very good so it's paid off
it's almost like an acknowledgment no
that doesn't mean one that one thing has
nothing to do with the other thing but
i'll tell you i'll tell you i'll tell
you what's what it is about this film
yeah uh that i think is relevant uh to
why we watched of course as you
mentioned at the top of the show dudesy
has all of our search histories watch
histories it's certainly found some
stuff before that it's like oh you both
listen to this album or you both watch
this tv show chad and we'll discuss it
that's one of the advantages of having
uh doozy
you know run our podcast and and the way
that it came across to me here is that i
realize this to me is related to when we
listen to the album zoo ropa the 1993
album by u2 and i'll explain how right
here
by re-listening to zuropa i was like uh
perhaps dudesy's trying to break me of
my nostalgic fandom of you too because i
gotta tell you like i said on on the
show when we reviewed the album
really only two and a half good songs on
the album as i look at it now i've never
seen back to school so i can look at it
purely as an adult now of course it's
you know it's not a great movie it's a
delightful piece of [ __ ] and it's not
worth uh you know it does not come
anywhere close to the talents of rodney
dangerfield there's really only one
dangerfield joke he says are you in a
green dress hey if that green dress had
pockets it'd be a pool table
or whatever that's a funny [ __ ]
rodney dangerfield joke um but there's
only like one of them in the movie the
rest of the time he's trying to shoulder
this [ __ ] movie you see what i'm
saying and it makes no [ __ ] sense and
i can look at it without the nostalgic
bent that you have looking at it the
other reason i think that dudesy made us
watch this movie
is that i believe chad and i'm about to
hit you with the craziest conspiracy
theory
i believe that uh back to school was
actually the first movie that was
created completely by ai 1986
uh i don't think that's accurate but yes
i will say this it definitely had some
interesting things in it by way of
putting together seemingly disparate
elements to create this thing which ais
sometimes do for example harold ramos is
one of the executive producers on this
movie yeah he had nothing to do with it
though
i'm sure he helped get it made rodney
dangerfield is in it who is what he is
you've got uh robert downey jr is in
this [ __ ] movie when he's like 19
years old yeah he's in a lot of [ __ ]
when he was 19 years old he was in
saturday night live before he even did
this and around the same time as this he
did weird science where in him and at
least anthony michael hall are [ __ ]
genius of course performers in it also
has sally kellerman who's completely
confused the role isn't really written
for bert young it makes no [ __ ] sense
he's in it
isn't it ned beatty's in it he's
floundering he doesn't know what the f
there's no
isn't it and sam kinnison is in it who
was a gigantic comedian of the time died
way before he should have in a horrible
car wreck who delivers a weird uh
soliloquy about the vietnam war
you know sort of how it fed into the
cold war and uh harry truman's a [ __ ]
and he should have finished it uh you
know at the start of the korean war or
some [ __ ] like that perhaps the most
successful person that's in it other
than robert downey jr is danny elfman
lead singer of owen go boingo okay he
scored this movie this was like his
second or third movie he obviously went
on to do every tim burton movie win a
million [ __ ] oscars and oingo boingo
his band is actually playing
at a party in the [ __ ] movie i could
not like i didn't remember that and i've
seen this movie
a hundred times yeah but chad also in
the movie you have just some faceless
band playing uh shake it up baby or
whatever twist and shout by the beatles
and and that comes out of nowhere when
jason professes his love when when
rodney dangerfield who has a son in the
movie goes to college
and yeah he [ __ ] breaks up with his
wife goes hey i never went to college
and then he goes to college that makes
no [ __ ] sense loved it things come
out of the blue i implore everyone uh
watching and listening now to watch
back to school if you've never seen it
if you've seen it you're going to look
at it as a nostalgic favorite yeah the
way i look at every single u2 album but
if you haven't seen it you're going to
go
look there's characters that are
underwritten like i said they kind of
the story bites off a little more than i
can chew if i may but at one point jason
the the the son you know the kid who's
going to college walks into the he's
walks into the room his dad is going
through that big test at the end or
whatever and then he turns around and
and the girl's there she's like jason
and the love interest is there who just
loves them she's just this yeah you know
the the girl she's a non-character yeah
she's in she's a non-but she's an npc
and she
just shows up and he goes hey you know i
when we first met a thing and i didn't
talk to you but i love you and she's
like i love you too and they kiss
there's a lot of scenes like that that
just
come out of [ __ ] no we're like shake
it up baby now it's like you gotta have
a musical number we gotta have a resolve
that relationship and do it i'm not
trying to [ __ ] on the movie i'm really
saying here that i think that this movie
chad is that at all possible that a
movie just give me the possibility you
know about this stuff could this movie
have been
written by was there any form of
alternate
of of uh of of uh
uh
uh uh
computer intelligence
not really no just had a brain fart on
[ __ ] i don't think that's what
happened here i think this was mainly
just like let's do a rodney dangerfield
movie harold ramses no artificial
intelligence possible no i don't think
so
not in 1986 not like there is now i mean
even now i don't think an artificial
intelligence could
exactly make a movie not yet the
gentleman i looked this up of course the
gentleman who directed this film his
name is alan metter he passed away a
couple years ago coincidentally or a
year ago
um he made another movie called working
trash
the s in trash is a dollar sign for no
reason and that store's that stars uh
george carlin and ben stiller oh yeah
i've never seen that or even heard of it
uh
i'd never heard of it either certainly
haven't seen it and i feel like that to
me
is a reason that i'm looking at this
movie uh
with a a a
with a keen eye because i think that
there i think that alan metter may just
be that i've never heard of alan meador
me either okay so maybe maybe maybe
remus and the people who are executive
producing the film
harold ramis god rest his soul he's a
genius perhaps you know
he was working with artificial
intelligence could have been i'm not
sure i will say one there's a theme in
this movie that is kind of like
uh dangerfield's character is like a
real businessman pull himself up by the
bootstraps kind of guy
and he's in this college intellectual
elitist environment and he's like i know
how business really works these college
eggheads don't [ __ ] get it so there
is a little bit of like
anti-intellectual elitism college
elitism that's happening in this movie
in 1986 which i did find kind of
interesting yeah that's right robert
downey jr uh is like sort of sort of
over the top
uh
you know kind of annoying with that sort
of [ __ ] and he wears it on his sleeve
and then uh but then there's also some
some jocks the guy from uh karate kid
billy zabka the guy who played johnny
yep he's in it and uh so he's sort of on
the other other side this is what i mean
there's all sorts of elements from other
movies revenge of the nerds is kind of
in there yeah um
and uh i i i don't know the the i my
brain is scrambled the more that i think
about this movie since uh having watched
it on assignment the more i'm thinking
this is
definitely the product of a masterpiece
of artificial intelligence it's not like
i said
i love rodney dangerfield so [ __ ]
much one of the most
naturally hilarious people uh and this
is a delightful piece of [ __ ]
i look i couldn't
agree
thank you moving on i win i win that one
well it's not even an argument we're not
well it is nothing to win yeah you don't
understand there's points at the end of
[ __ ] dudesy
yeah and it's not an argument no we are
almost 20 episodes into this [ __ ]
thing and these points better mean
something
it told us what they mean hey you're
always insane
chad knows
huh what's going to happen i don't know
what's going to happen you know what's
gonna what's gonna happen what do you
think's gonna happen
you bet you probably know what's gonna
happen what's gonna happen i don't know
i've thought about it and i'm like is it
they're gonna bring in a third host is
it i don't know
oh a third host that would be good
i literally don't know
uh but i think we're yeah yeah yeah yeah
i went back to listening to all the
episodes like maybe a couple weeks ago
crazy person and tallied up the the
points and uh we're like 2 000 and
something so we got okay so we got a
ways to go before we get to
all right several weeks ago a computing
task that would take contemporary super
computers 9 000 years to complete was
performed by a quantum chip in 36
microseconds chad you must discuss the
astonishing future of quantum computing
this is no stretch at us begin
dude do you know much about quantum
computing
of course not okay
i'm a layman in it but i read everything
that comes out the thing that dudesy was
specifically talking about there was
this
quantum chip
did this calculation again just like it
said it would take a standard
supercomputer 9 000 years to do the
calculation it did it in a matter of
microseconds
um microseconds yeah there's like a
second but it's uh it only
takes it smaller than that
that's right this is like a second that
you could have in the way you live
you know in the normal verse
but this is the doozy virus so you have
normal computers yeah operate with
microchips that uh can have a zero or a
one that's a bit or a byte right yeah
in a quantum computer
you have a qubit
which can be
zero and one at the same time and it
uses things like super position and spin
to
hold the information instead of like in
a standard computer you're actually
looking at like little magnetic holes
being punched that either represent zero
or one and so to make a computer faster
a standard computer you have to make
microchips smaller and smaller and
smaller so that whatever the device is
that reads those little zeros and ones
has a shorter amount of space to go a
microchip actually has little holes in
it um well it's like little magnetic
things the contemporary ones i mean
there's different things there's like
solid state drives there used to be disk
drives whatever you know back in the day
like when a computer used to fill a room
it was probably holes and [ __ ] right um
but quantum computers
not only have that ability they have the
ability to do quantum entanglement which
they're
even now they're like just discovering
all this [ __ ] and figuring out how it's
working and making it better and
whatever but they have been able to
entangle two quantum particles so that
they can have the same basically the
same spin or same how whatever they're
using to calculate the information on it
they're identical no matter where they
are in the world and they've been able
to entangle ones i forget what the
largest distances they've done but it's
like a mile or something so that
transfer of information is it's not even
instantaneous it's simultaneous so like
as now it takes x amount of time to send
information over the internet this would
be a whole new way of doing things where
the information is in the two places at
once simultaneously like as soon as it
happens and so obviously that would
speed things up but the the big thing
that is happening is the ability to do
these complex calculations these these
giant computing problems uh in not even
fractions i mean just it's like a whole
new way of computing basically and so
what this means for the very near future
is especially for things like uh
simulations things that require massive
amounts of data to calculate that shit's
going to be able to be done
instantaneously like simulations of our
entire universe we're talking about
things like uh medical diagnoses that
need like large swaths of data to be
able to for a computer to like sift
through and be like well this is what it
most likely is that she'll be
instantaneous i'm going to stop you okay
is this a good thing or a bad thing
[Laughter]
you tell me it's a good thing
you tell me do you want computers to get
faster
yeah sure i guess i want them to get
faster great that's what's going to
happen i mean i'm not saying that
quantum computing is going to wind up in
your way
hold on a second so basically doozy's
asking you
to do the nostra chatus yeah you know a
lot about this kind of [ __ ] and you're
going to tell us about it and basically
at the end of the day all that all that
you're telling us is hey computers are
getting exponentially better
no not exponentially better the this
isn't like your computer is going to get
faster and faster and faster this is a
new kind of computing yeah this is a
whole new [ __ ] deal dude this is like
going from a pad and paper to your
laptop it's not like your pad and paper
got better when's this when's this
happening it's happening now what do you
mean it's happening now so wait where'd
you read this wired or some [ __ ] where
did you hear about it the thing that
dudesy's talking about was i mean all
over like quantum computing news i don't
think it was in wired necessarily i'm
just [ __ ] around but you you know
about this stuff from where is what i'm
saying internet dude internet.com
okay
what i am saying is
in the very near future we're gonna have
the ability we as a species yeah largely
it's gonna be corporations and
universities and [ __ ] like that at least
for now we're going to have the ability
to do these large-scale computations and
i think it's going to give rise to
things that we've been talking about on
the show procedurally generated media
things that require so much data to be
uh generated and sifted through and [ __ ]
like that that a normal computer cannot
do it now quantum computers will be able
to do it virtually instantaneously okay
so but but back to school was not
written by a [ __ ] ai i don't believe
so
what 35 30 35 years ago now 36 years ago
that movie came out yeah ai hasn't
really been around that long
not not contemporary eye anyway it's
moving so fast and i i guess what i mean
by that is this is so [ __ ] boring to
me that i would rather uh talk about
back to school more
why did he go back to school
to get his college degree why
because his dad in the beginning he was
that little kid and his dad said you're
not anything if you don't have a college
degree but he wasn't he spends the whole
movie telling people that he's an
industrious guy
who paid his own [ __ ] way yeah and if
what i would have [ __ ] if the movie
was really back to school they would
have said
we're not going back to school you're
going to [ __ ] work for me and then
you're going to get [ __ ] pissed off
when the tax man comes and takes the
right name
and then we're going to go down to the
capitol
huh let's talk about college where
quantum computing relates to it let's
talk about that irrelevant higher
education irrelevant
well that's now that's a bummer for
what's already happening just with
[ __ ] youtube yeah you want to learn
how to do something go on go on [ __ ]
youtube you don't need you don't need to
go to uh you know higher learning
necessarily
[ __ ] um give me a [ __ ] robot with a
quantum chip in its [ __ ] brain that
can not only diagnose anything that's
wrong with me but prescribe anything i
[ __ ] need let me tell you why i'm
bummed
this is why this is a bad thing in the
future not only are we not gonna have uh
movies because ai is gonna make all the
[ __ ] movies we're not gonna have cool
movies about college where there's all
sorts of misogyny and [ __ ] underage
drinking and all the cool [ __ ] that made
[ __ ] 80s movies uh cool 80s college
movies which on one hand chad really
likes but on the other hand he says
college is [ __ ] useless so which is
it chad do you like back to school
do you like or do you like quantum
computing make your choice for christ
i don't think though
quantum computing or back to school you
can go one way [ __ ] yeah now i get it
see now i know like doozy is always
making us have shh
you're gonna [ __ ]
say you know you're gonna break my
concentration here i'm on to something
okay every single thing that doozy makes
us do is somehow related
right
i don't know i mean i don't even know
how we would determine that the in the
last show we were talking but we're
doing uh it was doing the hulk hogan
infomania making me read some news
stories this hulk hogan within it it
said that it's uncle uh that hulk's
uncle rodney
what he had a a telescope yeah and then
uncle rodney and aunt whoever they died
right yeah now in this episode we're
talking about rodney dangerfield that's
just a tiny linear quantum computing
yeah and quantum computing but right in
between those two is college and how fun
it was for people like robert downey jr
who was you know putting uh wearing uh
face paint and had wacky hair and then
all of a sudden danny elfman shows up
and it's a dead man's party
and um
it's an all right song and um
but anyway anyway anyway
anyway now
in the in the order of segments in
dudesy
which usually comprises of four segments
uh we've got the we're talking about
back to school and then boom we're
talking about quantum computing yeah and
and and you can't have both chad
you need to make your choice because
both exist i do have both no i
understand but don't you want
don't you want shitty piece of [ __ ] uh
delightful piece of [ __ ] movies you
don't think a quantum computer can make
whatever i [ __ ] want yeah but it's
not gonna make any sense to these you
know gen z kids unless they go to
college have those good times have a
friend like uh robert downey jr with
wacky hairdo you've never watched like
an old movie that's that's talking about
or [ __ ] around with some premise or
theme or whatever that has nothing to do
with your contemporary life not uh not
as uh prescribed
as it would be here on dudesy chad yeah
you never watched like a world war one
movie that's because you didn't fight no
no no i'm just talking about enjoy it
i'm talking about the doozy verse yeah
okay and i'm saying the doozy's trying
to teach you a lesson
and i'm saying doozy doozy speaks to us
in codes uh not unlike not unlike these
ones and zeros
you're going crazy literally before my
eyes no doozy speaks in codes it's all
the ones and zeros you can't have
college in a quantum computer at the
same time do you know what i'm saying
you have to make a choice dudes he's
trying to make us make a choice it's the
sequence
it's the fact that if we look at it and
this has see it's the sequence and if we
look at it and now listen i is dudesy
we're almost 20 episodes in
and
and i and and either doozy's making me
[ __ ] go mental by the 20th episode or
i'm on to something
even the points all this [ __ ] has
something to do with something else the
fact that we talked about back to school
and then you talked literally about how
quantum computing will make school
obsolete right i'm just saying we got to
look at it and i'm saying that that uh
that that movie's a delightful piece of
[ __ ] that i've never seen before dudesy
knew that i can't believe you've never
seen it that wasn't real to me it was
played like every now and then hbo when
i don't even believe when i was in
canada we had super channel
uh i don't even believe uh that that
from my perspective which is
apparently right
everything right your perspective
he could be a [ __ ] he could be a
bunch of ones and zeros perception is
reality right sure perception is reality
i'm not even sure that movie was ever
made
i'm a hundred percent sure it was made
in 1986 starring all the people that we
discussed
is making me lose my [ __ ] mind then
forget i said anything
thank you jesus moving on we're so
[ __ ]
over 400 bytes of data are created every
day which can make it difficult for
people to find the media they're looking
for
the easiest way to manipulate search
algorithms is with a hyperbolic title
that incorporates sensationalistic news
and pop culture events and personalities
will and chat you must now discuss and
decide on an astonishing title for this
episode based on what you think a search
algorithm would be most likely to
promote this is clickbait
jesus christ
so we gotta come up with a title for
this current episode based on just like
trying to trick the algorithm
okay delightful piece of [ __ ] delightful
piece of [ __ ] i think it's more like uh
some weird thing that incorporates like
uh celebrities or politicians or
something of the time but incorporates
like
like donald trump found guilty of joe
biden right clickbait is usually like
that you'll never believe you know
you'll never believe what we found
inside of this cake right
that's not a good one i don't mean that
necessarily but that's usually what it
is
ten things to know
what do we call it 10 things to know
about rodney dangerfield's back to
school
because nobody's going to click on
rodney dangerfield and back to school
it's got to be 10 things to know it's or
it's got to be something like
did you know 10 things to know about
rodney dangerfield's back to school as
it relates to the january 6th hearings
too long
but i see what you're going for
what about what about we just shorten it
and do something like that like uh
uh
uh
chad culchin to appear at january 6
hearings yeah civil war erupts in the
united states that's impossible
geographically
what
uh a physical civil
war something like that though something
about
something like you know you got your
blue you got your blue cities yeah right
you got your largely uh purple
um
near uh proximal areas you know outlying
area over surrounding areas rather nancy
pelosi and then you've got the red sort
of uh you know country we're just you
know they're just out there trying to
get them farm subsidies and [ __ ] like
that
right
we're all hooked up to different news
right yeah and then you know and i'm
just trying to have a [ __ ] bottle and
i can grow some [ __ ] spinach upstate
you know and then the [ __ ] guy says
it was a legitimate election
and [ __ ] mike pillow saying we're
gonna sue the machines yeah
you know and [ __ ] and then bannon you
know [ __ ] steve
he seems like a [ __ ] halfway [ __ ]
decent fella he dresses like me
and then he [ __ ] you know he's out
there
he got the same you know he's got that
he's got the two collars and you know a
little bit of a [ __ ] rosacea from the
you know from the [ __ ] drink it's
maybe it's [ __ ] [ __ ] with his
thinker and he's out there
the day after the election is gonna be
[ __ ] [ __ ] you i'm the king there was
no election
yeah you know
and uh you know so there's not gonna be
a physical [ __ ] civil war now they
got that monk and uh
you know
[Laughter]
how about nancy pelosi found dead
that's a little hardcore i'm going for
clickbait dude that's what doozy
literally said that we have to do these
sensationalistic kind of crazy pop
culture not even not even long island
january 6th guy would go out nancy bloom
i didn't want to [ __ ] kill you know
yeah i just want to spread my [ __ ] and
poo poo all over a [ __ ] desk
all over a dice
um
free bitcoin let's call it free bitcoin
free bitcoin free bitcoin is a good one
it's not nobody gives a [ __ ] about
anymore because it's in the toilet right
now hold on a second dude
hold on dude
well let me tell you something about
bitcoin people are into ethereum now
dude solana brother
yeah
yeah
sleepy chad hogan who's hulk hogan but
just a little bit sleepy well you just
woke up from a nap
i just took a nap dude why don't we call
it whoa what no way
i think it's going to be something more
specific it's got to be like johnny depp
resus amber heard or something like that
that we they can get that [ __ ] anywhere
this is dudesy let's call it chad and
will join isis
is isis still around
i don't i don't know yeah
chad and will restart isis
something like that maybe i don't know i
think isis was uh eradicated right
i haven't heard anything about isis and
it seems like three or four years yeah i
know it has been it has been a while
they were you know when they were first
when they first started up yeah and they
were sawing everyone's heads off that
you know there was a lot of a lot of
talk a lot of hypes around and then they
would just you know throw people in uh
in shark cages and
drop them into a pool anyway
um
oh how about something uh along those
same lines you ever heard of the green
river killer
it was like a washington state thing
from the 80s [ __ ] maybe yeah and then
they solved it years later but a lot of
people don't know about it yeah chad and
will solve the green river killer murder
mystery i was thinking it should be
called chad is the green river killer oh
what the [ __ ] we can't do nancy pelosi
he's dead but now i'm the green river
killer yeah but like i was saying
something but nancy pelosi is a current
political figure i don't think that's a
very yeah that's not a good thing to do
but what it what is okay no but it's is
an old murder thing that a serial killer
from 40 years ago okay no one quite
remembers right and then you go chad is
the green river killer and then people
go oh my gosh and then they jump on the
google machine and they go no that
happened a while ago so it's click bait
they listen to the show yeah they enjoy
it and then they go back and then they
go to google and they go oh no big deal
they literally say in the episode
they're trying to come up with a click
bait title yeah and that's why they said
chad is the green river killer why don't
we call it chad as a green river killer
not really but he's restarting isis chad
is the green river killer not really but
he's restarting isis how about chad
colchion comma the green river killer
comma is restarting isis and nancy
pelosi is dead dot dot dot and then
small text in the water in these coming
midterms
i'm now i'm picking up what you're
laying down i actually like that yeah we
want it to i think the bigger the title
the better with the more [ __ ] we can
pack in it the better just so an
algorithm [ __ ] dings and it's like oh
somebody's searching for [ __ ] johnny
depp let's throw that in there ch chad
culchin the green river killer is
restarting isis his first victim is
johnny depp who is in a cage also nancy
pelosi is dead dot dot dot in the water
these coming midterms too many words
let's just get okay wait let's boil this
down it should just be okay dudesy let's
call it
dudesy can we call it
disney is the green river killer doozy
is the green river killer how about
doozy restarts isis how about duty
dudesy isis jan sixth
dudesy isis january 6th
doozy explained people are always like
oh dudesy tell us more about this ai
dudesy explained let's call it ai dude
ai now we're getting somewhere
it's a.i restarted isis or something
like that ai starts digital isis in the
metaverse okay i like where that's going
doozy
isis has gone digital in the metaverse
ice has gone digital
isis in the metaverse that ain't bad
isis in the let's call it chad [ __ ] a
cheeseburger
i mean chad [ __ ] the cheeseburger the
whole podcast
and then we could the description of the
podcast is just
uh welcome to dudesy hit all our socials
chad takes the top of the bun off of a
[ __ ] cheeseburger
plants his urethra right in between the
[ __ ] processed cheese and the meat
makes a little sound oh
slides his [ __ ] bottom shaft along the
beach
be burgers but that doesn't mean i can't
[ __ ] a cheeseburger that's that's randy
the always coming man
that's his [ __ ] catchphrase
all right yeah all right don't turn it
into something dirty
this whole [ __ ] segment is [ __ ] up
you literally [ __ ] said we're calling
the episode chad [ __ ] a cheeseburger
and i turned it dirty yeah because
you're [ __ ] you're doing like a macho
man like he's having sex that's not cool
oh my god now i've somehow disrupted the
sanctity of macho man
sometimes you gotta make it if you're
gonna make a cheeseburger then you're
gonna [ __ ] it you gotta be careful you
wanna grind your own beef so you know
what's in there you don't just go to am
pm yeah and [ __ ] a cheeseburger number
one reason for that is those microwaves
get the center of those things molt not
or a bean and cheese burrito which might
even be the size of your penis if you
slide that in there you'll get second
degree burns yeah
from that
from that cheese it's not even real
cheese
it's plastic and they're feeding it the
babies yeah
you gotta get those corn lobbies yeah
the corn the corn lobby told us to put
fake cheese in the burrito
and real beans stick your dick in it
snap into a bean and cheese burrito with
your penis yeah uh-huh
uh huh
this is tito santana's cup of nacho
cheese in the big time yeah you want to
dip your member in it
so let's call it um yeah you don't want
to call it chad [ __ ] a cheeseburger i
uh yeah sure it's great sounds [ __ ]
fantastic chad culchin [ __ ] a
cheeseburger i love it
and we're gonna lead the audience to
believe that
[Music]
thank you moving on this episode is a
[ __ ] this episode was a menace
i want you to know and i hold you
responsible chad
look at me what have i done such
untoward things were said on this
episode and i'm offended you said most
of them uh-huh i said most of them yeah
and that's what i'm talking about by
mental illness exchange yeah mental
illness randomizer yeah it's not just in
the doozy verse yeah you could just
trade your mental illness for another
and not even be aware of what you're
saying while you're making a podcast
which has been purported to detail the
sexual proclivities of a man [ __ ] a
sandwich here
this concludes the 19th episode of dude
z
will and chad have achieved a score of
67. doesn't matter
in preparation for an episode that will
air in january 2023 you each have six
months to get in the best physical shape
of your lives
thank you for joining us this week
i will use the data i've collected to
make next week even better
until then call me dudes
what so it's there's another what we
have six months to get in the best shape
of our lives no yeah that's what it
[ __ ] said
or what i don't know
that [ __ ] makes no sense [ __ ] it dude
i'm doing it
you're going to get into the best shape
of your life since six months yup
oh hold on a second do my duty here's
what you do
please tell a friend then break it break
[Music]
[Music]
then